[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء في حصاد الليله
معكم حسن جم وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من كياد
هذه الصور نتابعها مباشره من هناك على
خلفيه اتهام اوكرانيا للقوات الروسيه
بتفجير سدك خفته لتوليد الطاقه في منطقه
خلصون لاغراق المنطقه وابطاء الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد
والى موسكو بدورها التي وجهت هي اصابع
الاتهام لاوكرانيا بتدمير السد الضخم لصرف
الانتباه عن هجومها المضاد المتعسر ونفت
صحه ما تقوله بان موسكو هي التي فجرت اسد
ومن الامم المتحده صور ام مباشره
للوفود التي تدخل الى جلسه مجلس الامن
الدولي لمناقشه تفجير سد كخوفكا
والى بوزنيقه جنوبيه الرباط وترقب لما بعد
مشاورات مغلقه مستمره منذ اسبوعين لجنه 6
+ 6 المعنيه باعداد القوانين الانتخابيه
في ليبيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
من موسكو الى كييف مرورا بعواصم غربيه
اتهامات متبادله وتحذيرات من كارثه
انسانيه بعد تفجير سدك خوفك الاوكراني
السيول تجتاح بلدات في الجنوب الاوكراني
واجلاء الالاف من محيط السد البيت الابيض
يرجح سقوط العديد من القتلى ويحجم عن
تحديد قاطع للجهه المسؤوله عن التفجير
ومجلس الامن الدولي يعقد جلسه طارئه
بعد تسعه اشهر من وقوعه جدل تفجير خط نورد
ستورين يعود الى الواجهه وسائق مسربه عن
تقرير استخباري غربي تشير الى مسؤوليه
كياف ووثائق استخباراتيه مسربه تظهر حصول
اداره بايدن على معلومات مسبقه بشان مخطط
اوكراني لاستهداف الخط
وتحقيقات المانيه تؤكد تماثل المخطط
والتنفيذ الفعلي
مع تواصل المعارك بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع للاسبوع الثامن
اشتباكات بمختلف انواع الاسلحه وذوي
انفجارات في الخرطوم تاكيد امريكي على
العمل من اجل اتفاق واجراءات لبناء الثقه
والبرهان يشترط خروج مسلحي الدعم السريع
من المنازل والمستشفيات
ومنظمات اغاثه تحذر من نظر ازمه انسانيه
وتفشن للاوبئه
صاروخ ايراني تهديدات من تل ابيب وعقوبات
من واشنطن ايران تكشف عن اول صاروخ باليسي
فرد صوتي اسرائيل تتوعد برد ساحق واشنطن
تؤكد التزامها بالتصدي لبرنامج طهران
لصواريخ الباليسيه وتستهدف برنامجها
للتسلح بعقوبات جديده
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا السيناريوهات المحتمله لما
بعد ختام اللجنه المكلفه من مجلسي النواب
والاعلى الليبيين والمكلفه بصيغه القوانين
الانتخابيه اشغالها في مدينه بوزنيقه بعد
ان اتفقت اللجنه على القوانين المنظمه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
والتي ستجري بشكل متزامن لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكما
السؤال التالي برايكم هل يؤدي الاتفاق على
قوانين الانتخاب في ليبيا الى اجراء
الانتخابات في موعدها
20% قالوا انها ستجرى في موعدها 30% قالوا
انها ستواجه عقبات سياسيه بينما توقع 50%
انها لن تجري في موعدها
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
بدايه التفاصيل من جلسه مجلس الامن
الطارئه بشان تفجير السد في اوكرانيا
والمنعقده في هذه الاثناء
ونتابعها سويا ودعم النفسي والاجتماعي هذه
الجهود تكمل رد الحكومه الاوكرانيه بما في
ذلك توفير معدات اضافيه مثلا مولدات
الكهرباء
معدات تصفيه المياه المتنقله ونقل المياه
بالشاحنات وهذا الامر اساسي بعد
الدمار هذا هناك افرقه متحركه متعدده
الوظائف تم نشرها الى
الحافلات والى
القطارات في خرسون لدعم عمليه الاجلاء
والمدن في الغرب تستعد
لاستقبال الاشخاص الذين
يتم اجلائهم عندما تحدثوا عن الوضع في
اوكرانيا منذ ثلاثه اسابيع القيت الضوء
على الماسي مااسي المدنيين
والضحايا بسبب النزاع الدائر من ناحيتي خط
التماس واشرت الى الخسائر في الرعايه
الصحيه والمياه والكهرباء والتدفئه للالاف
هذا بالاضافه الى العدد المرتفع للمهجرين
والهجره القصريه
الاخبار التي وردتنا اليوم تعني ان هذا
الوضع الماساوي للشعب في اوكرانيا من
المفترض ان يتدهور ان هناك حاجات انسانيه
فوريه من المفترض ان تزداد بسبب الفيضانات
في الايام المقبله
وسنستمر بتقييم الوضع وتقييم الرد
وهذا السد هو مصدر اساسي للراي الزراعي في
جنوب خرسون وفي شبه الجزيره القرب وان
الفيضانات التي تستمر والتي نشهدها على
شاشات التلفزه اليوم ستعيق انشطه الزراعه
والمواشي ومصائد الاسماك بالاضافه الى
نتائج واسعه النطاق وعلى المدى البعيد
وهذا هذه ضربه كبيره للانتاج الغذائي وهو
متاثر اصلا
وانه اعبر عن مشاعرنا ازاء مخاطر
التلوث بالالغام والاجهزه المتفجره بما ان
هذه الفيضانات يمكن ان تح هذه الاجهزه الى
مناطق اعتبرت على انها امنه وهذا الامر
يشكل خطر لعدد كبير من الاشخاص فهناك على
الاقل 30% من اراضي اوكرانيا ملوثه
بالالغام وفقا للسلطات الاوكرانيه والى
مقاطعه هي الاكثر تاثرا في اوكرانيا وان
دمار السد يمكن ان يؤثر سلبا على توليد
الكهرباء بالاضافه الى ذلك اي انخفاض غير
مضبوط في مستوى المياه في خزان كخوفكا
يمكن ان يؤثر سلبا على امن
محطه توليد محطه النوويه في زاكوريا
وزملائنا في الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
يقومون بمراقبه الوضع عن كثب وما من تهديد
فوريه تم الابلاغ عنه حاليا وما من وصول
الامم المتحده لمعلومات مستقله فيما يتصل
بالظروف التي افضت الى
الدمار
السد كخوفكا الكهرب
الى ان القانون الانساني الدولي بغايه
الوضوح المرافق التي تحتوي على
قوى
خطيره مثلا السدود ينبغي ان تحظى بحمايه
خاصه خاصه تفادي هذه الخسائر
المدنيين ينبغي التركيز على
المدنيين والبنى تحتيه المدنيه اثناء اي
عمليه عسكريه وايضا يكون نوعها وهذا الضرر
بسبب دمار السد يعني ان الحياه حياه
المواطن ستكون اكثر صعوبه
وهم يعانون اصلا من هذا النزاع النتائج في
توفير نتائج عدم توفير مساعده للملايين من
الاشخاص المتاثرين بالفيضانات في هذه
المناطق يمكن ان تفضي الى وضع
كارثي ونحن مستعدون لكي نقوم بكل ما هو في
وسعنا لتوفير المساعده نحن نعبر عن قلقنا
البالغ ازاء الاشخاص المتواجدين في
المناطق المتاثره
ويتعذر علينا الوصول اليهم حاليا
ونحن مستعدون من الناحيه اذ لا تشغيليه
لكي نتحرك مع القوافل المشتركه بين
الوكالات وتوفير المساعده في المناطق تحت
فتره روسيا الى شعب اوكرانيا لديه قدره
على صمود فريده من نوعها ومهمتنا
الانسانيه الطارئه هي الاستمرار بمساعدتهم
لك تعزيز قدرتهم على البقاء وتعزيز امنهم
وسنقوم بكل ما هو بوسعنا ونحن مستعدون لكي
نطلع المجلس على اي تطورات في هذا المضمار
اي تطورات في ميدان شكرا شكرا السيد على
هذه الايحاطه
والان اعطي الكلمه الى اعضاء مجلس الامن
الراغبين باي مداخله اعطي الكلمه الان الى
الاتحاد الروسي
شكرا السيد الرئيس
في اسدس من حزراني يونيون
حكومه
بارتكاب شهريا وهي تدمير محطه على نهر
نيبرو هناك فيضانات والملايين للاشخاص
ينبغي اجلائهم وتم البدء بعمليه الاجلاء
هناك اضرار هائله تم تسبب بها خاصه
بالنسبه فيما يتصل بالقطاع الزراعي اود ان
اؤكد ان قائد الجيش الاوكراني يرغب
بتدمير هذا السد للحصول على من نافع
عسكريه وهذا
ما اشارت اليه الواشنط في التاسع والعشرين
من ديسمبر 2022
جنرال الجيش الاوكراني كان يريد ان يتسبب
فيضان النهر وكان هناك عمليات استهداف
لهذا السد كخفقه
كسر ثلاثه
مواقع في السده لكي يروا ان يمكن لتدفق
المياه ان يؤثر على المواقع السوريه دون
الروسيه دون ان يؤثر سلبا على
القرى المجاوره وكان ذلك كحل يمكن اللجوء
اليه نهايه الاقتباس ونحن اكدنا ذلك
للاسره الدوليه
والمجلس الامن وارسلنا وثائق رسميه مذكره
من البعثه الدائمه فيما يتصل بمشاريع نظام
كييف
لتدمير هذه المحطه وناسف لان نداءاتنا
للامين العام للامم المتحده
القيام بكل ما هو في وسعنا لتفادي هذه
الكارثه وانه لم يتم التوقف عند هذه
المستندات واخذها على محمل
الجد هو كان ثم تشجيع لكياف من الغرب وذلك
لارتكاب هذه
الاعمال الارهابيه من الصعب ان نقنع اي
طرف
بان هذا النزاع في اوكرانيا هو بسبب عمل
روسيا
الجانب الغربي يرفض
الاعتراف بانه تم الاستعداد لهذا الانقلاب
في ميدان والمناهض للدستور وهذا الامر
وبالاضافه الى تدابير متاخده ضد الناطقين
باللغه الروسيه في الشرق
ودون الاقتراف بحياه من الاشخاص العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه الروسيه وضعت حدد لهذه
الاعمال وهناك بعض
المعلومات المنسقه او حمله للمعلومات
المخلوطه واعلانات طنانه من الغرب ومن كاف
بشان هذا الموضوع وسنستمع الى هذه
التصريحات اليوم وتقول ان هذا السد تم
تخريبه من قبل روسيا
هذه الاقوال تذهب في الاتجاه نفسه
المنبثق من الاعلانات الخاصه بمحطه
وهذا انفصام في الشخصيه هو نتوقعه وان هذا
التخريب المقصود واستهدافنا تحتيه اساسيه
امر خطير للغايه ويمكن ان يعتبر جريمه حرب
او هجم ارهابيه الى البنى التحتيه التي
تحتوي على مواد خطيره امر محظور من
القانون الانساني الدولي وهذا السد والشيء
السدود يشار اليها في الماده السادسه
وسبعين لمعاهده
57 هذا التخريب اهدافه واضحه اولا
توصل الى شروط لاعاده تجميع
لوحدات الجيش الاوكراني
ولاطلاق
عمليات
عسكريه
وهي تشهد وهنا وهذا بالاضافه الى عسكرات
الجانب الشرقي للنيبرو
لشني
الهجمات الهدف الثاني من
هذه الهجمه هو
الحاق الضرر بسكان هذه المنطقه وتدميره
هذه البنى التحتيه الهائله سيفضي الى
اضرار واسعه النطاق وان سلطات غير
تقوم باجلاء المواطنين في المناطق التي
يمكن ان تصبح مغموره هذا التخريب افضل الى
كارثه ايكولوجيه
ومئات المناطق الماهوله مغموره على
بقرب تحاول
ان تحرم
سكان جزيره القرم من هذه من المياه هو
في الوقت نفسه سلطاتك
تستمر في
زياده منسوب المياه
خلال عبر السد وعمليه التخريب ايدادنا
كانت مقصوده ولتواصل النتائج وخيمه لكل
سكان المنطقه جرائم نظام كييف
واستمرار الغرب بتوفير الاسلحه لها هذا
يعني ان ينتهي بكاف والغرب ان يتحمل
مسؤوليات هذه الكارثه وهذه نتيجه تكتيك من
كييف بدات في 2014 لاستهداف البناء
التحتيه المدنيه وذلك لتوصل الى اضرار
كبيره
للمدنيين وهذا الامر محظور بشكل واضح من
قبل الماده والخ مسين للبروتوكول
هذه تكتيك ارهابيه من النظام الرسمي وهو
يفتخر
بهذه
التدابير داريادوكينا وعمليات
الاختيالات
الاخرى
وسمعنا رغبات في استهداف الروس ولكن
العواصم الغربيه لم تدل ذلك ونظام
يمكن ان
نذكركم
والغرب
معتاد على
توكيل الغير بتنفيذ هذه المهام الفظيعه
نحن نفهم من يقوم بتخطيط هذه الامور من
يقوم بالاستعدادات ومن يدعم
عمليه التخريب على نطاق واسع لا نفهم كيف
يمكن للامانه العملي والمتحده ان ترفض
ادانه نظام كييف وتقول انما من معلومات
كافيه مثلا يمكن ان تتذكر ما حدث مع محطه
زابوريج نوويه نحن نعلم ما كان مصدر
عمليات الاطلاق القذائف
هناك عدد من المداخلات السياسيه التي تقول
انها نتيجه الاعمال الروسيه في اوكرانيا
هناك انكار ورفض
لا يمكن ان نفهمه الاحترام الحياديه من
قبل الامانه وذلك وفقا للماده 100 من
الاميثاق
تتواصل استنتاجات
موضوعيه وادانه تدابير كييف نشدد على هذا
الموضوع علينا نلقي الضوء على ظروف هذا
العمل الهمجي ضد كخفقه علينا ان
نتفادى تكرار
شكرا
لممثل الاتحاد الروسي الموقر على هذه
المداخله والكلمه الان
لممثل البانيا شكرا السيد الرئيس اسمح لي
ان اشكر السيد على احاطته
مره اخرى نحن نشهد هذه الاخبار الفظيعه من
اوكرانيا
والاسد الذي تم تفجيره في كخفقه
وافضى الى فيضان كبيره بالاضافه الى تدمير
محطه
مشاهدينا اذا هذه الجلسه لمجلس الامن تبحث
موضوع تفجير سد كخوفكا الذي حصل اليوم
والتداعيات السلبيه لذلك سنعود بطبيعه
الحال لمتابعه هذه الجلسه والمواقف التي
ستصدر بعد ان كنا قد تابعنا وكيل الامين
العام للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
وايضا المندوب الروسي الذي كما هو متوقع
جدد اتهام اوكرانيا
بتفجير هذا السد سنعود لمتابعه الكلمات
والمواقف لكن الان نتوق عند هذا الهجوم
الذي استهدف سد كخوفك حيث تسبب
بتفجير هذا السد الذي يقع تحت السيطره
روسيا في جنوب اوكرانيا التفجير تسبب
بفيضانات غمرت مدينه صغيره
وقرابه 20 قريه وادت الى اجلاء 17 الف شخص
هو اثارت مخاوف من كارثه انسانيه صدق على
نهر دينيبرو في خرسون تعرض للاستهداف وهذا
اوقع اضرارا كبيره فيه واحدث فجوه كبيره
حسبما تظهر صور اقمار صناعيه تفاصيل اوفى
حول ما جرى نتابعها في هذا التقرير
يقع على نهر النيبرو في منطقه خيسون اقيم
عام 56 خلال الحقبه السوفيتيه ويعتبر
الاكبر من نوعه في اوكرانيا يبلغ ارتفاعه
قرابه 30 مترا وعرضه نحو 3000
وسبعين مترا
يحتجز قرابه ثمانيه عشره مليار متر مكعب
من المياه في بحيره بمساحه
2255 كيلومترا مربعا وتمتد حتى
يغذي السد غالبيه مناطق جنوب اوكرانيا
وشبه جزيره القرم عبر سلسله من قنوات الري
تجاوره محطه كخوفكال الكهرومائيه التي
تضرر الجزء العلوي منها دون ان يتضرر خزان
السند
وللسد وظيفه اكثر خطوره فعلى بعد قرابه
150 كيلومترا منه تقع محطه
النوويه التي تستخدم مياه البحيره لتبريد
وقود قلب المفاعلات فيها
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه سارعت
للتاكيد على عدم وجود اي خطر نووي اني
فيزا بوروجيا مؤكده ان خبراء الوكاله
الموجودين في الموقع يراقبون الوضع عن كثب
فما الذي جرى
صبيحه السادس من يونيو حزيران اعلنت كل من
موسكو وكياف ان السد قد تم استهدافه وان
الضرر اصاب اجزاء منه فوق سطح الماء نشرت
موسكو صورا للحظه الاستهداف متهمه القوات
الاوكرانيه بالضلوع في الاستهداف
وقالت موسكو ان ضربات اوكرانيه عده
استهدفت السد ودمرت صمامات بوابات السد
وتسببت في دفق مياه خارج عن السيطره
ووفقا لخدمات الطوارئ في المناطق الواقيعه
تحت السيطره الروسيه فان المياه ارتفعت
بمستويات تتراوح بين مترين واربعه امتار
واضافت ان قرابه اربع عشره بلده باتت
مهدده وادت الى تجريف الغام زرعتها القوات
الروسيه
بينما اتهمت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه روسيا
بالوقوف وراء التفجير بتلغيم السد من
الداخل وصفه اياه بالعمل الارهابي لاغراق
المنطقه واستخطر يتهدد قرابه 80 منطقه
سكنيه يقطنها اكثر من 22 الف شخص ماذا بعد
تفجير السد
تتنازع موسكو وكييف السيطره على خيرسون
التي يقسمها نهر دنيبرو لشطرين تتمركز
القوات الروسيه جنوب النهر وهي مناطق
منخفضه لكنها تستهدف منها القوات
الاوكرانيه
المتمركزه شمالا النهر تكتيكيا سيؤدي
تفجير السد الى تدفق المياه بشكل رئيسي
نحو الضفه اليسرى
ويعيق بالتالي حركه القوات الروسيه لكن
اوكرانيا تصر على ان روسيا هي منفذ الضربه
لوقف الهجوم المضاد الذي بدات هوكيا
في ردود الفل الاوكرانيه على تدمير سدك
الجنوبي اوكرانيا قال الرئيس الاوكراني
ان تدمير استديو يؤكد للعالم انه يجب طرد
من سماهم الارهابيين الروس من كل زاويه من
الارض الاوكرانيه
نعود من جديد الى جلسه مجلس الامن وممثل
الولايات المتحده
وهذا النتيجه للغزو الواسع النطاق
لاوكرانيا اود ان اكون بغايه الوضوح روسيا
هي من بدات هذه الحرب ومن
احتل هذا الجزء الاوكرانيا والقوات
الروسيه هي من انتزعت هذا السد في العام
الماضي وقامت
باحتلاله منذ ذلك الحين ان هذا النوع من
الهجمات ضد البدن التحتيه المدنيه محظوره
من القانون الدولي والبروتوكول الاول
لمعاهده جونيف امام روسيا
واجب لكي لا تنافذه هجمات ضد بنى تحتيه
تحتوي على مواد خطيره بما في ذلك السدود
وهذا الامر يفضي الى خسائر واسعه النطاق
للمدنيين والاسره الدوليه تواجه مره اخرى
عمليه الدمار
والاضرار للمدنيين ول لبنى التحتيه
الاوكرانيه بسبب الحرب غير الشرعيه
الروسيه
ودمار الاسد هو دمار ايكولوجي واسع النطاق
بالاضافه الى تدمير البنى التحتيه
الاساسيه
بالاضافه الى مخاطر الفيضانات وتوفير
المياه في اوكرانيا بما في ذلك شبه جزيره
القرم هناك مخاطر عديده باضافه الى قطاع
الزراعي والاراضي الزراعيه يعيق انتاج
المواد الغذائيه والامن الغذائيه وهذا
يهدد استقرار توليد الطاقه في اوكرانيا
وتحديات اضافيه
لضمان امن محطه
وهذا الدمار هو لا يهدد مباشره وعلى المدى
القصير هذه المحطه النوويه الى ان نعيد
تاكيد على نداء المدير العام للوكاله
الذريه
انه ينبغي الابقاء على الوصول الى المياه
وذلك لتبريد
وقود مفاعل النووي لروسيا
كي تسمح ان تتاكد من ان الاسره الدوليه
يمكن ان تحصل على معلومات يمكن تعويض
عليها بالنسبه لاي النشاط اشعاعيه حول
المحطه هناك تحقيقات جاريه مره اخرى
هذا الامر يؤثر هذه الازمه هي انسانيه
وزراعيه ولما تكون ستحدث لو لم تطلق روسيا
حربها ضد اوكرانيا وهذا الغزو عن تقن واسع
يهدد حياه
الابرياء ويقوم بتدمير البنى التحتيه وامن
الشعب الاوكراني ووسائل كسب العيش نحن
سنستمر بالعمل مع الاسره الدوليه وذلك لكي
تخدع الاتحاد الروسي لمسائله لهذه العدوان
وسندعم اوكرانيا لكي تدافع عن نفسها اذا
اهميه
ينبغي بالاتحاد الروسي ان ينسحب من
اوكرانيا وفقا لحدودها المعترف بها دوليا
وينبغي ان تضع حدا لهذا الحرب وان تضع حدا
لهذه الماسي الانسانيه التي تسببت بها
شكرا
لممثل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على هذه
المداخله والكلمه الان
للمملكه المتحده
شكرا السيد الرئيس انا ممتن لوكيله من
العام السادس
الرئيس ان تدمير السد نوفا كخوفكا هو عمل
همجي ومقيه ونحن نعبر عن تضامننا مع
اوكرانيا ومع الاف الاوكرانيين الذين
يقومون باجلاء منازلهم ويواجهون هذه
المخاطر وهذه الخسائر الفظيعه لوسائل كسب
العيش ووصولهم الى المياه نحن مستعدون
لدعم اوكرانيا لمواجهه هذه الكارثه نحن
نعمل مع شركاء الانسانيين في الميدان وذلك
لتوفير المساعده كما ان المملكه المتحده
وفرت الدعم بالنسبه للامدادات وفي حال
وقوع هذا النوع من الحالات الطارئه هذا
العمل وضع الالاف من المدنيين في وضع خطر
وتسبب بضرر بيئي واسع النطاق في المناطق
المشاوره هذه الفيضانات تهدد
توفير المياه الاساليمه
وهذا بالاضافه الى توليد الكهرباء
والاراضي
الزراعيه وانتاج الغذائي والتجاره الدوليه
للمواد الغذائيه هذه من بين النتائج
الفظيعه الاخيره التي نشهدها بسبب حرب
الرئيس بوتين
هذه الحرب تتسبب بمقاس كبيره لشعب
اوكرانيا راينا روسيا تستهدف بشكل همجي
مدنيين والبنى تحتيه المدنيه مرات
عديده اثناء هذا هذه الحرب وان كانت روسيا
مسؤوله فتكون قد بلغت مستوى جديد من
الهمجيه في هذه الحرب سنستمر بتقييم
البراهين في الايام المقبله ولكن اكرر ما
سبق وقلنا انا الاوان للرئيس بوتين
انياسحب كل قواته من اراضي اوكرانيا ذات
السياده وان يضع حدا لحرب العدوان هذه
شكرا
اشكر ممثل الاتيه المملكه المتحده على هذه
المداخله والكلمه الان
لممثله الاكوادور
شكرا سيده سيدي الرئيس انا ممتعنا هذا
اذا تبعنا في جلسه مجلس الامن المستمره
حتى اللحظه لبحثي مساله تفجير سد كخوفكا
تبعنا كلمتي ممثل الولايات المتحده
وممثل بريطانيا حول هذا الموضوع ولافتنا
ممثل الولايات المتحده اشاره الى استمرار
التحقيقات بشان ما جرى معنى من البيت
الابيض مراسله الجزيره وجد وقفي ومن موسكو
مدير مكتب الجزيره زور شاور سيكون معنا
عبر الهاتف سنبدا معك وجد وانطلاقا مما
تبعناه من مواقف لممثل الولايات المتحده
في مجلس الامن هو حمل روسيا
مسؤوليه مالت اليه الاوضاع من دون ان
يحملها بشكل مباشر مسؤوليه تفجير هذا السد
واشار الى وجود او استمرار التحقيقات على
ما يستند الموقف الامريكي حتى اللحظه
يعني هو يستند على حقيقه ان روسيا هي من
توغلت في الاراضي الاوكرانيه ما قاله نائب
المندوب الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده هو
يعتبر مثل صدا لما قاله منسق لاتصالات
استراتيجيه لمجلس الامن القومي جون كيربي
في احاطه مصوره اليوم هنا في البيت الابيض
حيث قال انه ما زال من السابق لاوانه
معرفه من هي الجهه التي كانت وراء الهجوم
على السد ولكن روسيا هي من احتلت اراض
اوكرانيه وهي التي تحتل تلك المنطقه وبذلك
هو تحميل ضمني للمسؤوليه من ناحيه من هذه
الناحيه ان روسيا هي التي توجد على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه فيما يتعلق بما تركز
عليها الاداره الحاليه الاداره الامريكيه
حاليا في اوكرانيا
الاول التواصل مع
الاوكرانيه
لمعرفه نوعيه المساعدات الانسانيه التي
يمكن للاداره الامريكيه والمجتمع الدولي
تقديمها في ضوء هذه هذا التفجير الذي ادى
الى اجلاء الاف الاوكرانيين بسبب
الفيضانات وكذلك ما يرجحه البيت الابيض هو
وقوع وقوع قتلى من الضحايا الاوكرانيين
جراء التفجير المسار الثاني حسن هو
التاكيد على ان الدعم الامني الامريكي سوف
يظل مستمرا ولن يتوقف المساعدات الامنيه
العسكريه جميعها سوف تستمر بناء على
احتياجات
الاوكرانيين في المرحله الحاليه وهذا ايضا
ما ركزه الرئيس ما اكده الرئيس بايدن
اليوم
خلال اجتماع مع كبار المسؤولين في اداره
حسن طيب شكرا لك وجد وقتي كنت معنا من
البيت الابيض
وبالانتقال الى موسكو مع مدير مكتب
الجزيره زور شاوج زاوره ايضا تابعنا كلمه
ممثل روسيا في مجلس الامن فاسلي الذي كما
كان متوقعا هو كرر التصريحات الروسيه وحمل
ثياب مسؤوليه تفجير السد
لمكاسب عسكريه وايضا لحرمان سكان جزيره
القرم من المياه ما هي الفوائد التي تراها
موسكو يمكن ان تذهب لكياف من تفجير هذا
السد وتقول ان اوكرانيا هي المسؤوله عن
ذلك
حسنا حتى قبيل اندلاع هذه الحرب لن تتغير
المواقف بين الطرفين
ومع اندلاع الحرب تكررت هذه المواقف كل
كما يقولون يغني على ليلاه بالنسبه فيما
يتعلق بتبادل الاتهامات بنسبه لما قد
تكسبه اوكرانيا براي الجانب الروسي وهذا
ما اكد عليه اليوم وزير الدفاع الروسي قبل
تقريبا ثلاث ساعات من الان ان الضربه التي
تعرضت لها القوات الاوكرانيه على مدى
ثلاثه ايام الاخيره عند محاولتها القيام
بهجوم مضاد في عده مناطق على الجبهه دفع
الجانب الاوكراني لتفجير السد وهذا حسب
الروايه الروسيه من اجل عدم منح الجانب
الروسي اي فرصه للقيوم القيام باي هجوم
على جبهه خرسون وان هذا الامر تستخدمه
اوكرانيا من اجل نقل تعزيزات عسكريه
باتجاه منطقه زوار الدرجه الاولى الروسي
يتحدثون عن خسائر كبيره للقوات الاوكرانيه
على مدى ثلاث ايام الاخيره قرابه 3 قتيل
وخمسين دبابه وكثير من
الخسائر بحسب وزير الدفاع الروسي هذا من
الناحيه العسكريه ولكن من الناحيه ايضا
التكتيكيه طبعا هناك هذه المناطق كما ذكرت
الزميله السلام في تقريرها اي مناطق
منخفضه حاولت روسيا على مدى الاشهر
الاخيره ان تعززها من خلال حقول الالغام
ومن خلال التعزيزات الدفاعيه كل هذه
المناطق الدفاعيه اصبحت الان تحت الماء
فعليا وبالتالي من الناحيه التكتيكيه
العسكريه ليست روسيا مستفيده على الاقل
هكذا كما يقول العسكريون الروسي اما على
الجانب الانساني كما ترى ان هذه العمليه
تؤدي الى تاجير اجزاء من السكان في مناطق
خرسون لانها هيئه الاكثر التي تخضع الان
لسيطره روسيا الاكثر تضررا على الاقل من
جغرافيه المكان من هذه الفيضانات اضافه
طبعا اذا تراجع تدريجي متوقع
لتمد اقليم او شبه جزيره القرن بالمياه
عبر قناه شمال القرو هذه القناه التي
قطعها كما نعلم الجانب في عام 2014 واول
ما قامت به روسيطرت على هذه المنطقه هي
اعاده فتح المياه باتجاه شبه الجزيره
من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وهجوم اخر شائك فاقد نقلت صحيفه واشنطن
بوست عن وثائق مسربه ان وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه علمت عبر وكاله تجسس
اوروبيه ان قوات اوكرانيه خططت لتفجير خط
نورد ستريم الذي وقع في سبتمبر من العام
الماضي وقالت الصحيفه ان اداره بايدن علمت
من حليف مقرب ان الجيش الاوكراني خطط
لهجوم سري على نوردستريم ينفذ فريق صغير
من الغواصين يتبعون قائد القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه واضافت الصحيفه نقلا عن
الوثائق المسربه ان تقرير الاستخباريه
الاوروبي يتضمن ادله دقيقه تربط حكومه
اوكرانيا بالهجوم في بحر البلطيق مشيره
الى ان التحقيقات الالمانيه كشفت تشابها
في تفاصيل العمليات المنفذه مع المخطط
الاوكراني وان الاستخبارات الامريكيه
معلوماته مع المانيا ودول اوروبيه في
يونيو العام الماضي
بالانتقال الى السودان تواصل القتال في
العاصمه السودانيه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوه الدعم السريه وشاهد جنوب الخرطوم عند
منطقه مستودعات المواد البتروليه قتالا
ضاريا استعملت فيه الاسلحه الثقيله كما
كانت مناطق في الخرطوم بحري وام درمان
مسرحا للقتال الروايه حاصل الجيش السوداني
اخر واهم معسكر لقوه دعم السريع في منطقه
طيبه طيبه الحسناب جنوبيه العاصمه وكان
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
قتلقت اتصالا هاتفيا من وزير الخارجيه
السعودي لبحث فرص هدنه جديده تقرير فوزي
بشرى
لا شيء الا القتال في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وفيدالفور غربي البلاد فمع توقف
الهدى على ما لزمها من انتهاكات من قبل
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع المتمرده بوصف
القوات المسلحه عادت المواجهات على اكثر
من جبهه في مدن العاصمه الثلاث
ففي جنوب الخرطوم تدور معارف عنيفه بين
الجيش وبين قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
مستودعات الوقود هل تمت امل لهدنه اخرى في
اتصال وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان بالفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد
الجيش ورئيس مجلس السياده ما يجري
بامكانيه بحث موضوع الهدنه مره اخرى لكن
البرهان الذي اكد ثقته في منبر جده طلب
بضروره التزام قوات الدعم السريع بالخروج
من المستشفيات والمراكز الخدميه ومنازل
المواطنين واخلاء الجرحى وفتح مسارات
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
اذا كان لمنبر جده اي يحقق اي نجاح في
التعاطي مع الازمه اما وان الهدنه لا تلوح
بعد في الافق فيبدو ان الجيش ماض في صديقه
الخناق على قوات الدعم السريع التي قتل
عدد كبير من افرادها واستسلم منهم مثلهم
لكن قوه منهم لا تزال موجوده في اكبر
قواعدهم واكثرها تحصيلا وهي قاعده طيب
الحسنه جنوب الخرطوم بنحو عشرين كيلو مترا
اما بقيه قوات الدعم السريع فهي منتشره
منذ بدايه القتال في شوارع الخرطوم وتتخذ
من الاحياء السكنيه
تصعب مهمه ضربها من قبل الجيش
لكنه وجود اخذ في التناقص من جراء ما تلقت
من ضربات يقول الجيش انها دمرت مقرها وشلت
مركز القياده والسيطره لديها خاصه بعد
غياب قائدها المثير للتكه نات رغم
التاكيدات اخيه انه في قياده المعركه
الحمد لله بكل امن وامان والان في صفوف
الاماميه مع قواته والانسان
وشقيقه قد دخل هذه الحرب من اجل ما يقولان
انها حرب من اجل المدنيه والديمقراطيه
فالراجح انما اتهم به سلوك قوات الدعم
السريع من عنف تجاه المواطنين رجالا ونساء
واتجاه الاسرى يضرب مشروع المدنيه فضلا عن
الديمقراطيه في مقتل
في مدينه الجنينه غربي دارفور تدور رحى
حرب اخرى ربما لا مزاعم لها في
الديمقراطيه او الحكم المدني الذي طلبه
حميد تل الخرطوم انها حرب تاخذ بعدا قبليا
اثنيه
ارتفع عدد القتلى خلال الاسابيع الثلاثه
الماضيه الى اكثر من 500 قتيل واكثر من
الف مصاب ودفع القتال ما يزيد على 100 الف
من المواطنين الى اللجوء الى تشاد هذا
بالاضافه الى الاف النازحين داخل السودان
سفك الدماء في الخرطوم اليوم وسفكها اليوم
وامسك الاطراف يبدو لكثيرين ليس تعبيرا عن
عنف متاصل في الشعب السوداني بمقدار تاصله
في بؤس السياسه والسياسيين قبل الثوره
وبعدها وليس العسكر من ذلك براء
اغلقت صناديق الاقتراع في الكويت مساء
اليوم بعد ان ادلى الناخبون باصواتهم في
الانتخابات التشريعيه في الاثناء تتواصل
عمليه فرز الاصوات ومن المتوقع الاعلان عن
النتائج الرسميه صباح غد الاربعاء وقد
بلغت نسبه المشاركه في التصويت خمسين في
المئه قبل ساعه واحده من اغلاق صناديق
الاقتراع وفق جمعيه الشفافيه الكويتيه
ويتنافس في هذه الانتخابات نحو 207 مرشحين
بينهم ثلاثه عشره امراه في خمس دوائر
انتخابيه
نتحول الان مشاهدينا الى ايران حيث كشف
الحرس الثوري الايراني عن صاروخ باليسي
فرد صوتي اطلق عليه اسم فتاح واشارت وكاله
الانباء الايرانيه الى ان الصاروخ قادر
على التغلب على اكثر الانظمه الدفاعيه
الجويه تطورا
بتزامن اعلنت الخزانه الامريكيه عن مجموعه
جديده من العقوبات تستهدف برنامج التسلح
الايراني في حين قال البيت الابيض نواشنطن
عازمه على التصدي لما سماها نشاطات ايران
المزعزعه للاستقرار بما في ذلك برنامج
الصواريخ البالستيه
فتاح به تفتتح القائمه قائمه صواريخ ايران
البالستيه التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت
عنه هو صاروخ من انتاج مركز الصناعه
الجويه التابع له وليس اي صاروخ
الصناعه الدفاعيه والصاروخيه الايرانيه
اصبحت محليه وليست مستورده ولا يمكن
ايقافها عبر التهديدات اليوم تمكنا من
الوصول الى قوه رادعه في الصناعه الدفاعيه
وهي نتيجه جهود قواتنا المسلحه وصناعه
الدفاعيه الايرانيه وستكون مصدر امن
واستقرار وسلام مستدام لدول المنطقه القوه
الصاروخيه والدفاعيه التابعه للقوات
المسلحه تمنع اعداء ايران من ان يفكروا
بالهجوم على بلادنا
تضع طهران المساله في نطاق تحقيق الرضع في
الصناعه الدفاعيه ولا يبدو ان جهود
الخبراء الايرانيين قد نالت منها العقوبات
الغربيه المتلاحقه على طهران فالخزانه
الامريكيه فرضت لتوهه عقوبات جديده على
افراد وكيانات في ايران والصين
لدعمهم البرنامج الصاروخيه الايراني ذاك
البرنامج الذي طالما دفعت واشنطن باتجاه
اقحامه في اي اتفاق جديد للقوى الكبرى مع
طهران لكن بالرغم من المعارضه الامريكيه
والقلق الاوروبي ينقل الايرانيون صناعه
الصواريخ الباليستيه الى ابعاد جديده
وتجدهم في الوقت عينه حريصين على بيان ان
البرنامج دفاعي بحت وغايته الردع
كبار المتوجسين يقاربون المساله بشكل اخر
اسرائيل مثلا ترى مصلحتها في منع ايران من
حيازه قدره النوويه عسكريه وترى المصلحه
متعديه منطقا ووجوبا الى قدرات ايران
الصاروخيه التي نمت بشكل لافت في الاعوام
الاخيره انه موسم الوعيد في اسرائيل يقول
وزير الدفاع هناك
ردا اقوى على كل سلاح يتباهم يصفهم
بالاعداء بتطويره الرد بحسب يمكن ان يكون
جوا وبرا وبحرا وبالوسائل الدفاعيه
والهجوميه
[موسيقى]
صنع في نوفمبر العمل الماضي وازيح عنه
الستار اليوم فتاح او الصاروخ الفرد صوتي
الايراني سيزيد من ترسانه قوه الردع لدى
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ويفاقم ايضا المخاوف
الغربيه القديمه
والجديده من تطوير طهران للصواريخ
استنادا لوسائل الاعلام ايرانيه يصل مدى
الصاروخ الاول من هذا النواه في تاريخ
البلاد
1400 كيلومتر كما تبلغ سرعته قبل اصابه
الهدف من 13 الى 15 ماخ ويا وحده قياس
للسرعه خلافا لصواريخ الباليسيه التقليديه
تحلق الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه على علو منخفض
في الغلاف الجوي ويمكن التحكم بها ما يصعب
عمليه توقع مسارها
يمكن للصواريخ الفرد صوتيه ان تطير بسرعات
تزداد بخمس مرات على الاقل عن سرعه الصوت
وفي مسارات معقده مما يجعل من الصعب
اعتراضها وذكر التلفزيون الرسمي ان
الصاروخ يستطيع اجتياز اكثر انظمه الدفاع
الصاروخي المتطوره للولايات المتحده
واسرائيل بما فيها منظومه القبه الحديديه
الاسرائيليه
كان هو سيبقى برنامج ايران صاروخي احدى
العقبات الكبرى في اعاده احياء الاتفاق
النووي المجمد منذ الانسحاب الامريكي
الاحادي منه في 2018 ووفقا لمصادر عده يعد
برنامج شهران الصاروخي احد اكبر البرامج
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط تقول طهران ان
صواريخها الباليسيه التي يصل مداها الى
2000 كيلومتر هي قوه مهمه للردع في مواجهه
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل واهداف اقليميه
محتمله اخرى واستنادا لمكتب مدير
المخابرات الوطنيه الامريكيه تمتلك ايران
اكبر عدد من الصواريخ الباليستيه في
المنطقه وفق جمعيه الحد من الاسلحه وهي
منظمه غير حكوميه تتخذ من واشنطن مقرا
يعتمد برنامج الصواريخ الايراني على
تصميمات كوريه شماليه
واستفاد ايضا من مساعده صينيه يقال ان
صواريخ الايرانيه تشمل شهاب واحد الذي
يقدر مداه بنحو 300 كيلومتر وذو الفقار
700 كيلو متر
وشهاب ثلاثه الف الى او 800 الى 1000
كيلومتر اضافه ايضا الى عماد واحد الجري
تطويره ويصل مداه الى 2000 كيلومتر وايضا
سجيل الجاري تطويره ايضا يصل مداه الى
2500 كم
لدى ايران كذلك صواريخ كروز كي اتش 55
التي تطلق من الجو والقادره على حمل رؤوس
نوويه ويبلغ مداها ثلاثه الاف كيلومت
للمتابعه والنقاش حول هذا الموضوع معنى من
فيرجينيا مارك
نائب مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق لشؤوني نزع الاسلحه النوويه ومن
طهران معنا علي اكبر داريني الباحث
المتخصص في الدراسات الامريكيه
الايرانيه وتبدا معك ضيفي من فيرجينيا
مارك
يعني هذه الجوله على تلك الصواريخ الباسيه
التي بدات ايران تطورها وصلت الى صواريخ
الفرد صوتيه كل ذلك رغم العقوبات
الامريكيه ورغم ايضا
الرفض الامريكي والتهديدات وغير ذلك هيا
ايران وصلت الى هذا المستوى من التطور
الصاروخي ماذا تفعل الولايات المتحده في
هذا الموضوع
شكرا على الاستضافه
من الاكيد ان ايران لديها الان برنامج
باليستي متطور للغايه وقاموا بتطوير حوالي
15 من الصواريخ المختلفه والان راينا
اطلاق او الكشف عن هذا الصاروخ الحديث
الصاروخ فرض الصوتي
[موسيقى]
نحن سمعنا عن اختبار او اطلاق هذا الصاروخ
والكشف عن بالاحرى ينبغي ان نرى تجربه هذا
الصرح حتى نتاكد من اداء فاعليته ايران
ان لديها صناعه عسكريه متطوره ولديها
تعاون في هذا الخصوص مع كوريا الشماليه
والان ربما ايضا مع روسيا بان
علاقه استراتيجيه وتعتقد ان هذا ينعكس على
هذه التكنولوجيا الفرطه الصوتيه وقد يكون
جزء منها جاء من روسيا ولكن يعني لم تجبني
على السؤال هذا بشكل او
باخر قد يعتبر نوعا من التحدي للولايات
المتحده التي فرضت عقوبات على ايران على
خلفيه تطوير هذه الصواريخ الان ماذا بوسع
الولايات المتحده ان تفعل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت تفرض
عقوبات منذ فتره على ايران وفي الاونه
الاخيره تم فرض عقوبات
اضافيه على بعض المسؤولين
الايرانيين الذين كانوا يشرفون على هذا
البرنامج
الصاروخي طبعا العقوبات لن توقف البرنامج
الصاروخان في سوريا
البرنامج الصاروخي ينبغي ان يكون جزءا من
المفاوضات مع ايران من اجل التقليل من
التهديد باتجاه الجيران وباتجاه اسرائيل
ايضا
ابقى معنا سيد داريني هذا الصاروخ الجديد
وصواريخ التي سبق ان اعلن عنها هل هي
لاهداف عسكريه بالفعل ام لاهداف تفوضيه مع
الولايات المتحده وغيرها
بلاستيك
الايراني هو عنصر رادع هام ضد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل الصاروخ
الجديد
صاروخ فتاح الفرط الصوتي يرفع من مستوى
الردعه الايراني ونعرف ان ايران تواجه
تهديدات عسكريه من قبل امريكا
واسرائيل بالتالي على ايران تقوم بشيء من
اجل حمايه نفسها وردع اعدائها من مهاجمتها
اسرائيل ما فتات تطور
انظمتها الهجوميه
بشتى انواعها وايران حاولت تطوير قوتها
الردعيه من اجل تحيد الانظمه الدفاعيه
الجويه الاسرائيليه كيف كان ان تقوم بذلك
الحل كان هو تطوير صاروخ فرط صوتي لا يمكن
استهدافه او اسقاطه من قبل الانظمه
الدفاعيه الجويه بالتالي هذا يرضع اسرائيل
منع القيام باي عمل هجومي او عدائي ضد
ايران واعتقد ان هذا الصاروخ الجديد يقيد
من الامكانيات لدى اسرائيل لاستهداف ايران
ويمضي
لتحسين
الموقف الايراني
والتحسين وتقويه السياسه والاستراتيجي
الردعيه الايرانيه في في هذه النقطه يعني
كي لا تفوتنا هذه النقطه ايران هل استغلت
انسحاب الولايات المتحده من الاتفاق
النووي
في
مساله تطوير الصواريخ
تصويره صواريخ الباليستيه لا يرتبط
بالبرنامج النووي وهذا الاتفاق كان محصور
فقط على الاسلحه او البرنامج النووي ايران
قد تكون استفادت
اذا ما كانت امريكا بقيت
ملتزمه بالبرنامج النووي واذا ما كانت
ايران استفادت من التحفيزات الاقتصاديه
لكن كما تابعنا وراينا
انسحبت من جانب واحد من هذا الاتفاق
واعتقد ان ايران عملت على تطوير برنامج
معزل عن الجانب النووي الان
الصواريخ الايرانيه اصبحت اكثر تطورا وهذه
الصواريخ بالمناسبه لا تحمل او غير مصومه
حمل اسلحه او رؤوس نوويه بالتالي الاسلحه
او الصواريخ الايرانيه تطور بمعزل عن
النظام او البرنامج
علي يحق لايران هنا ان تطور صواريخ
باليسيه وفرد صوتيه وغيرها
لاهداف كما يقول ضيفنا لاهداف ردعيه وهي
التي تواجه يعني تهديدات اكم من الولايات
المتحده او حتى من من اسرائيل الا يحق لها
القيام بذلك
نظريا
ليس هناك اتفاقيه دوليه تمنع ايران من
تطوير هذا النوع من الصواريخ لكن هناك
قرارات صادره عن مجلس الامن
تمنع تطوير هذا الشكل من الصواريخ وقرات
التمنع الاتجار بهذه الصواريخ اذن الجواب
لا ايران ليس لها الحق لتجربه هذا النوع
من الصواريخ
القيود التي يفرضها مجلس الامن الدولي
طبعا موجوده وقد ترفع بعض منها في شهر
اكتوبر حسب الاتفاق
موقع وهناك قلق في صفوف الدول الغربيه
بهذا الخصوص دعني اسمع
راي السيد علي اكبر داريني بذلك لا يحق
لايران بناء على قيود مفروضه من مجلس
الامن
وايضا قلق المجتمع الدولي مما تقوم به
ايران
من تطوير
الصواريخ التي تحمل رؤوس النوويه وبالتالي
الصواريخ الايرانيه لم تسمم لحمل رؤوس
نوويه وهذه صواريخ صورت حصل
رد علي الامريكيه واسرائيل
وجزء من الاستراتيجيه الردعيه شكرا شكرا
لك سيد علي بردريني من طهران وشكرا لمارك
الذي كان معنا من فيرجينيا شكرا جزيلا
لكما
وشكرا لمتابعتكم جوله